[Music]
hello everyone this is dm rashfield and
today i'll be doing the gm choice
lecture for the st louis chess club
and
one of the things i love to do whenever
a
major tournament is going on is i'm
always looking at the games every day
i'm just trying to catch it i love
looking at new games
so it's definitely something i enjoy
doing and today the game that caught my
eye in the tata steel tournament which
is the big
international tournament going on in the
netherlands
is that the game between niels
grandelius and fabiano carowana
and by the way hey everyone i am looking
at the youtube chat so if you have
questions or answers to the questions i
hate talking for just an hour
so i usually will be asking questions
and having you guys answer
so i can definitely see the the chat
hey davina how's it going
uh
all right
so
the so i'm actually wanted to do this
game because i found it to be quite
interesting it wasn't one of the leaders
i would say that um
fabi fabi is having a really disastrous
tournament by his standards he
lost a game because he basically hung a
rook which
is kind of unheard of at that level it
happens once in a very long while
but it was kind of crazy and so by his
standards he's not doing so great and
grandelias is a really strong swedish
player but he's struggling a ton
and
it's just it's kind of sad like it's
when strong players struggle but in a
tournament like this which is brutal
it's sort of what happened so i would
say neither player is in form
but
both players were definitely ready to
fight which i like it wasn't it was
clear that neither player was satisfied
with just well i'm having a bad
tournament let me just try to play safe
both players played really exciting
chess and i thought that this game
was very interesting so
without further ado it was a french so
i've noticed that fabi likes to play the
french for a win when he's trying in a
game where he really wants to be able to
press
so we have an advanced french
c3 knight c6 knight f3
so here there are two main moves there's
queen b6 and bishop d7
i don't want to get into the theory too
much i have to say though from a
personal perspective i always like the
bishop d7 more because i feel like it's
more flexible queen b6 puts more
pressure on the center
at least immediately but bishop d7
sometimes allows for rook c8 ideas and
you don't have to put your queen on b6
where sometimes at least to me it feels
a little misplaced
so i personally like this bishop d7 move
but of course it's more taste than
objective reality
so bishop e2
and this is a very common continuation
so both sides are developing logically
he puts the knight on g6 if you put it
on f5 sometimes you're vulnerable to
bishop coming back to d3 and hitting
your knight
so bishop e3
bishop b7
knight bd2
castles and rookie one
so we have a very standard position
white's basically playing in the center
playing all logical moves black hat
black is castled
so this position i found quite
interesting
so
this position believe it or not
fabi had in a previous game against
vicho lagrave i believe
and he actually won a really nice game
by playing the move rook c8
and in that game veitro lagrave played
the move knight f1
cd4 cd4 knight before
and black just got an excellent position
knight c2 is a really really annoying
threat he ended up playing bishop d3 but
once you give up that bishop you're
really not playing for very much and i
think black's already better
but
something very clever happened here so
typically when
a player
loses a game they go over the game and
they try to figure out what they've
wronged but sometimes when players win
games they don't do that as carefully
top players that's not true
but
and this is a really great lesson in
that because even though fabi won this
game
he looked at this game and he realized
that maybe rook c8 runs into this move
a3
and at the very least this is very
annoying because now you can't play cd
cd
and your rook on c8 is not always that
well placed
so
he actually comes up with a very very
clever move which is a5 and i don't know
if this is preparation or if he just
smelled a rat and kind of varied but
this is a very very common technique
because
you don't really want to walk into your
opponent's preparation
whenever you can especially that kind of
level of preparation you're basically
playing against the computer you want to
kind of throw the game off and i
personally really like this a5 move
because now
you still have some of the same ideas
except you're more flexible so for
example grandelious plays a3
and now fabi simply plays a4
and i really like this because i feel
like he's gained queen side space but
he's flexible with his other pieces he
can still play for other things
but life continues here
grendelius plays bishop d3 which makes
sense the bishop really doesn't belong
on e2 the reason he develops it to e2 is
to make development easier because he
doesn't have to worry about his d4 pawn
so he puts it back on d3 where it's a
lot better
takes takes
and here
i think that fabi plays a really really
excellent move but not at least to my
mind not an obvious move so i'm curious
what you guys come up with
so what would you guys play as
as black here
oh
so i'm seeing lots of suggestions uh
moves like f6 and f5 i think are a bit
too soon so for example if you play here
immediately
and i take you kind of have an issue of
you have to worry about pieces landing
like bishop g5 trait like if rook takes
for example i can play bishop g5 and
trade off the bishops which can be very
very annoying
uh amongst other things but this in as
itself would be kind of at least a
little bit irritating for me
so i don't really love playing that
immediately
net a5 is actually a very very typical
building move
but here i actually think it's it can
get you into trouble
so knight a5 makes sense right you're
trying to play b5 knight c4 and improve
but now white goes for this g3 h4 idea
and the problem you have is that if you
allow h4h5 your position is very very
bad
but
if you play f5 for instance
i can take
so let's say you play rook takes once
again
i play h4
and the problem now is that
h5 is already very scary and because
your net's on a5
if this happens for example i can
actually just put my knight here
and already you're in huge trouble if
you try to take d-takes your king's
side's going to get wrecked with ideas
like bishop moves queen c2 even or queen
g4 to g6 if you have to move your knight
the knight on e5 is great
so even though you
you you know played knight a5 you
neglected the center so it's very very
important that you always have your mind
on your opponent's ideas
because fabi knew that knight a5 is a
good move for him but it also takes away
control of the center which makes f5
harder to play
so he plays a very very clever move here
which is h6
this move looks a little bit strange
but the idea is it keeps pieces out of
g5
and now for example if the move g3 f5
the situation's a lot better once again
you kind of want to take this if you
leave the pawn on f5 you're kind of
blocked for a long time
so it takes rook takes
and here if i move like h4 he can simply
play bishop d6 guarding e5 h5 knight ge7
and notice how he has perfect control
over here there's no bishop g5 there's
no knight g5
and the knight can come to f5 if
necessary
so keeping that in on c6 is very
important to play against this idea and
this move h6 even though it looks a
little strange
actually guards against this
so it's a really really clever defensive
move
but i think that it actually makes a lot
of sense with f5 even though it loosens
up this knight on g6
so here grandelias plays queen e2
and in this position i don't know that
fabi's move is the move i like best
but he played a very fobby style move
so i don't know if that's that's a hint
for you guys but see if you can figure
out what he did or what you'd rather do
here so what would you guys do
because grandelias just played like you
know a normal building move he didn't do
anything to
uh extravagant
so i really like trent's idea of f5
and the idea is basically you're you're
still forcing the capture pretty much
rook takes f6 and you kind of play the
way i suggested
uh with bishop d6 next and then slowly
build and i think your position's fine
like i think it's about equal you know
in that range
i do think queen e2 is a bit better than
g3 i think it's more useful i don't
think the pawn on g3 is always so
wonderful
depending on the situation but in
general i'd say it's about it's similar
to the other position and you're doing
fine so this is kind of what i'd like to
do
but when i say a fabi style move what i
mean is it's a very ambitious move it's
a move that
takes risk like he's definitely a player
who's not
risk averse he's someone who doesn't
mind you know creating risk and and
playing a move that unbalances the
position further
uh there are some players and it doesn't
even matter his situation whether he
needs to win the game or not this is
just how he likes to play
so what's a move that's more unbalanced
rather than trying to play to secure the
center what's another way you can play
that's really interesting
so i would say a move like bishop g5 you
have to be very careful of because
you're creating a very weak pawn
structure so after something like takes
takes queen h5 i think you're
experiencing lots of problems bishop
takes g5 is happening your knight is
very loose if you move the knight you
get mated which would be
quite embarrassing
so rook b8 i like the idea of but it's
not very foggy style it's very slow b5
is the fabi style move which is what he
played so the whole idea of this
is that
he's expanding on the queen side he's
trying to play for b4
and he doesn't mind sacrificing a pawn
so if grandelias were to take this pawn
his idea is actually very clever he
plays rook b8
and he's basically saying if you do
nothing he's actually threatening some
tactics here for example knight takes e5
as a tactical shot so let's just say
rook c1 knight takes e5 and you're
threatening this bishop so you'd have to
take and then knight
takes back and this pawn exchange is
very very good for you
again maybe he has crazy stuff like rook
takes bishop but probably just knight
takes e5
and if white takes the pawn
and he takes on b2 he has a position
where
he's down a pawn but he has very active
pieces and this a pawn is kind of just
weak like this is one of those extra
pawns there are some positions where
extra pawns are very meaningful here i
would say that the fact that black
completely controls this side of the
board means that the a pawn's actually
not going to be that useful
so it's actually a really really clever
idea
grandelias on the other hand does
something which i think makes a lot of
sense which is that he basically ignores
the pawn he says fine i can't take the
pun
and now
he plays queen b6
h4 so grandelias is going for the attack
which makes a lot of sense and this
position i think is very very tricky
so one of the main things is h5 is
coming so what piece do you think black
wants to move in this position what do
you guys think
so bishop d8 is possible but that's a
very ugly move to have to play right
so something like bishop d8 the problem
here is that i think the knight on e7 is
quite bad
and i'm also very unsure how you're
going to battle against this idea so i
could play g4 g5 looks very strong but i
could also play bishop b1 queen d3 and i
don't see how you're blocking this
diagonal if knight f5 i have g4
g6 is of course too horrible to
contemplate and i feel like you're just
going to get butchered here
so this setup is not very harmonious
so what would be a better
way to do it
yeah so we need to move the f8 roxor and
i can go to f8 there's a saying with a
nano f8 you can't get mated this saying
is patently false you most certainly can
get mated with the nano f8 i've been
mated with an f8 many too way too many
times
but i would say that it definitely helps
in defense quite a bit
so here's the question you guys both
have the right idea you want to bring
the rook over but do you want to bring
it to c8 or b8 and in this in this case
i think the question is very complex
so i'm wearing a mask by the way so you
guys know i always get this question
there's usually someone else in the room
so
it's not just me
i'm not protecting myself from you guys
believe it or not
all right
so which square
it actually
it actually is a very complicated
question i actually think fabi got it
wrong and i'm not blaming him because
first of all i'm sure i'd get it wrong
many times but also
i think that it's a very subtle point
so you want the rook on the a file so
rather than playing rook c8 rook b8 you
want rook fb8 so you keep the rook here
that that's very logical especially if
you're playing for b4 because you want
the rook guarding your a pawn that makes
a lot of sense
yeah this is one where to me rook c8 is
more intuitive and that's what was
played in the game because you want your
rook on this open file maybe it helps
you play b4 knight takes it just feels
kind of nice
but there's an issue with it so i think
in the game
grandelias played knight f1 which i
actually don't like as much
but let me show you what happens if
let's say he played more aggressively h5
knight f8
and now g4 what would you guys play here
as black because
i can tell you when i analyzed this game
i was extremely terrified here
like what are we doing
this this g5 move is coming and it will
not be pleasant
so net h7 i thought of but the problem
is now i just play king h1 followed by
rook g1
and
g5 is coming
like you're not stopping it
so i think that this is going to be
really unpleasant
and queen d8 again is is a reasonable
idea but once i get a rook on g1 i'm
going to be able to force through g5
there's no way you're going to stop me
in any kind of long-term capacity
and the problem is this g5 moves comes
so fast and
there's no clear way to deal with it so
one move i looked at for example is net
a5 trying to you know play with the rook
on the c file
but again g5 and i i just couldn't make
this work knight takes g5
h6 is really deadly there's like so many
threats so i thought you had to try to
take and take this pawn
was the only try
but now white has a really excellent
move
see if you guys find it believe it or
not i think it might be the only winning
move
but it is a really really strong move
so h6 looks natural you have to be
careful though moves like knight c4
threaten a lot of stuff
uh even moves like f6 are possible
trying to get out of the the attack so
like for example of h6 i think f6 might
be a slight issue
it doesn't look like an issue it looks
like an insane move but how do you
actually deal with it right if pawn
takes pawn takes i don't think it's so
easy if you try to play knight f3 i can
give a check on 8g4 which is a problem
so
it's actually quite uh complicated
bishop f6 looks like too much i think i
can take this bishop
and my queen can come back and defend i
don't know if you want to give up that
much
knight f3 makes sense but again queen g4
check
so the killer move it turns out is queen
f3
so the main idea now is that you cover
all these squares so i'm just going to
play h6 next and you can't play f6
so the only tri i saw was knight h7 but
this does not end well you play takes
and this is the key move and again i
checked this with computers so obviously
it's not the easiest thing but i think
the key is you play this move
and the problem is this queen is not
stable and you have no moves and next
i'm going to play h6
so for example if knight c4 and this is
again a long way down the road
once again i build my position with rook
d3
and you actually just have no defense h6
is coming and you cannot stop it in any
way shape or form
it's actually just really nasty
so even though you're up some material
you're gonna
be in huge trouble just to show you how
it could go let's say you play rook fade
to guard against the pawn
i play rook c3
and then h6 and the key is that my rook
is very secure on this square it doesn't
hang
so
let's say you try to play rook g8 to be
able to take i can take this pawn
takes queen h3 check and then rook g3
and now i'm ready to play here and this
is going to be
very very bad
and yeah exactly suzanne the bishop on
d7 is a really terrible piece so
obviously this is not a realistic you
know this is
i analyzed you know i could check it
with computer but i was very curious why
grandiose didn't go for h5 g4 here and i
think it would have been very strong
after rook fb8 h5 is still a reasonable
idea
but now white black goes for b4 and with
the rook and queen lined up this idea is
actually quite annoying so for example
if white plays king h1 if you try to
play g5 right away
i can take and the whole point is that
here i take queen takes and because my
knight's still on c6 your queen can't
move to f3 i'm threatening this pawn so
you'd have to try something like this
but now i can grab this pawn even
with the idea that on takes
i can play the move f6 and i have a fork
yeah and the thing is they didn't think
so because they have to just play this
game over the board which is really
really tough when you're looking at it
with analysis like i did later
it's a lot it's a lot easier especially
when you're curious about something and
you always have the choice of turning on
the engine right like they don't have
any of this they have to figure all this
out which is really really difficult
um i would say so g5 here doesn't quite
work so let's say after b4 they play the
move king h1
here i can actually play bishop c8 and
this idea is really cool you're aiming
for bishop a6
and this is one of the keys of playing
putting the rook on b8 that you have
this bishop c8 to a6 idea
which is really really difficult
and yeah matt i would say that at least
from what i looked at allowing g5 was
really really bad in that position but
here for example rook g1 bishop a6 you
don't actually checkmate so easily i can
take
take here and play takes and queen b5
and your queen's getting chased around
and you're not going to have time to be
able to checkmate me especially without
your lightspeed bishop
so a lot of different subtleties here
but i think rook fb8 actually would have
been significantly stronger but only
because of this h5 g4 idea and this
ability to play b4 followed by trading
off this bishop on d3
so i was very curious myself because it
wasn't something that was intuitive like
for me rook fc8 makes a lot more sense
but i couldn't find anything against h5
g4 so sometimes you you come up with
ideas just based on necessity just
because h5 g4 was so strong
instead grandelious played knight f2 f1
and this is a very typical kingzine
attack which is kind of like the opening
he's playing
idea of activating the knight via h2 g4
but in my opinion at least it's just too
slow and fabi really showed this he
played b4
knight h2
once again probably wouldn't be my
choice i still would rather attack more
gen more directly with h5 g4 maybe
knight g3
rook f a b 8
but grendelius does have a really clever
idea
so once again i kind of like g4 although
with the n on h2 it makes less sense
right like the
the knight looks weird but the idea is
you're going to play g5 followed by
knight g4 but here fabi can take and
play queen b2
and already he's creating some
difficulties the move queen
f1 is possible but now he can play rook
b3
so he's threatening the bishop he's
threatening the pawn on a3
and this position i think is going to be
very difficult if he tries to play g5
now i can take
so if knight takes g5 i can simply take
on d4
so probably bishop takes is a bit better
but i can still take
and play queen takes d4
and again you're just you're you're kind
of collapsing a little bit it's not so
easy to hold this all together
so i i don't think that this is really
going to work out so easily for white i
i think it's playable but
it's not so simple so grandelias plays
knight g4
uh fabi takes
plays queen b2
so here i actually think queen f1 might
be a slightly more accurate move but
it's a bit of a sad move to play
and it's not so obvious how it works
after queen b3
after rook b3 sorry it looks like
white's in huge trouble but in fact he
can play this and take the rook
and then the idea is bishop d2 and the
problem is the queen has to be on b2
where it's not so wonderful
i want to highlight it red but it's not
letting me it's okay
in any case the queen on b2 is actually
a little bit misplaced so it gives white
some chances to get counterplay but once
again this is not a very obvious
continuation he played the move knight
d2 which i actually think is really
clever
and it leads to some interesting play
so my first question is
do you think that fabi should can and
should grab the pawn on d4
what do you guys think
that's very clever jimmy but you have to
be careful after bishop takes first of
all the the
the queen hangs after knight takes d4
right so
you wouldn't then lose
but if you would lose why would you lose
after knight takes d4
so let me put on the board knight takes
d4 is actually very very bad
for for black but the question is why is
it bad
well if you trade first and then sack on
h6 i simply take and i don't actually
see where your follow-up is my queen
seems to cover most of your squares
so if that was your idea i don't quite
get it
so knight takes h6 i think is a much
more powerful move
so if i play king h8 you can take on f7
and move back it doesn't help the
situation at all
so let's say we take then queen check so
probably bishop g5 is the best try but
it's still very very sad after we trade
in queen takes
but for example if king h8 we don't even
take the knight we just take on h6 and
your king is basically mated
so this would be a very very sad way to
lose the game
so instead fabi played a very very
important move here
so given that what we know about the
position now what do you think fabi's
important move is
yeah queen g4 is is a key that's why the
whole idea of knight g4 right um i think
that grundelius played a slow idea but
it definitely has some poison once the
knight gets to g4
so he puts the king on h8 which is
really an important move
and i would say this phase of the game
fabi played amazingly accurately like
this was even by his standards i would
say he must be happy with uh the way he
played this part of the game because
it was really incredible how many
accurate moves he had to play because
grandelias's
attack may have been a little unsound
but to prove it you have to be so
accurate so gondelius's first move was
queen f3
and here i actually think it's not so
difficult what move do you think fabi
would play here
so knight d4 you again you have to be
careful queen takes f7 allowing that
move looks very very dubious to me
so i think you're correct bishop e8
is a better move
so far so good right our bishop on e8
guards the f7 pawn it kind of helps
defend
but here grandelias throws us for
another loop he plays the move knight f6
and the ability to calculate and look at
tactics
accurately in a position like this is so
important
and this is where you have to know what
to do because you can take lots of
things or you cannot take lots of things
but the ability to know what to take and
not to panic is really tricky
so what do you think you should capture
now if you should capture anything as
black
what do you do your opponent just
plunked the knight on f6 and is laughing
in your face
well not laughing so much but it
definitely looks very dangerous so
do you think you should take the knight
do you think you should take the d4 pawn
do you think you should take the a3 pawn
the ultimate obnoxious move
you guys have good intuition
knight takes d4 it is definitely the
time if you try to take this knight
off only awful things are coming your
way i mean queen f4 takes the pawn looks
very strong but probably simply i take
this and the problem is that bishop d6
queen g4 you cannot guard against g7
so
this is a monumentally huge problem
so trying to take this pawn is going to
only take the knight sorry it's only
going to lead to sorrow taking with the
bishop doesn't help you at all
and i don't think i have to tell you why
takes a3 wasn't good i mean i think it's
not good for several reasons
so he takes on d4
uh thank you milo uh so knight takes d4
and here gondalias plays queen g's pour
and here in my opinion fabi plays a very
human move which is probably the move i
would choose as well
or at least the main move i would look
at and it's a perfectly okay move it's
not the best move though so we'll see if
you can find fabi's move but also see if
you can
what other moves you can spot because
this position is is very complicated
yeah i definitely don't agree with net
f6 i think knight f6 is an excellent try
so first guys you have to ask yourself
what is grendelius
trying to threaten here
that's your first question if you play
knight c2 you walk into a very very
powerful threat that white had what do
you think that threat might be
ah jimmy spots it bishop takes h6 this
is
a very very sad way to to lose a game i
think because you can't take the bishop
due to mate
and if you try to take the the knight
for example
i probably just take this bishop and
even though your queen can come back
i
i don't know i have some doubts about
this position maybe this isn't even the
most accurate way to do it but uh
like i can also threaten your queen
first right like in this position i can
play
for instance rook a b
one uh i obviously didn't analyze this
line so i'm
not 100 positive but something like this
first
now maybe take the rook and then maybe
take so the idea now is if you try to go
for this
i can simply take your knight at the end
of the line although the bishop hangs so
maybe you have to do this first or
perhaps bishop f4 is very strong trying
to bring the bishop here
ah the rook hangs though that's a
problem so
maybe i have to go here
this is what happens when you don't
check a line in a really complicated
game but this looks very bad because
even if you bring the queen back
i can take and play h6 and i'm still
crashing through over here
so i'm not exactly sure but this looks
very very bad for black to me or at
least very dangerous
so i don't think trying to play with
knight c2 is the best way here
so what else can you do
i will say though that you had the right
idea with knight c2 like
there's something very important that
knight c2 did which maybe didn't do it
in the best way but is one of the keys
to this position
but i'm not totally sure knight c2 like
it's very close to working so
yeah so knight f5 is what fabi played
which is quite logical basically just
trying to
keep white
keep black pre-oc keep white preoccupied
on the king side like basically just
defend the king side and this is a very
very logical move it basically kills a
lot of the attack
makes perfect sense
however there was even a stronger move
here it turns out
and yes joe this is a very head-hurty
game i will say that that's true this is
really complicated and having to face an
attack like this one of the things i
found
is that
when you face like gm's of my level like
mid-2500s say attacks like this work out
a lot because we're gonna just mess it
up
you'll get to check me that's not always
of course i'm not saying i'm going to
get mated every time but
it happens it can happen right you face
an attack of this strength you kind of
collapse a little bit sometimes
when you face 26 50s less often when you
face people of fabi's level you know or
2750 plus they defend so accurately that
even if you have a promising attack to
actually finish it off is so difficult
um
so i found that you know player that's
one of the things that makes those
really strong 2700s so tough is that
they defend
very accurately
so knight f5 again is the safe move
97 i've heard suggestions for i don't
get how it stops
well first of all i don't think it stops
bishop takes d4
oh sorry sorry not bishop takes d4 i
probably take the bishop first and then
play queen takes d4 and i think that's
just a piece right
because i'm guarding my knights
and the the queen with the bishop right
and knight c8 threatens mate on g7 yeah
so i think the the best one is actually
knight c6 which again is a really tough
move to play because you're walking into
bishop takes h6
but the idea now is that after takes
you can take with the queen and after
bishop g5 you have queen d4
and the knight guards the queen the
queen the queen exchange is really
strong so it turns out that black's
doing quite well here
but it's not so easy to just play this
way and i think that
fabi just had his doubts and i don't
know what the time situation was or
anything else but knight f5 is just very
safe
so he takes on e8 grendelius does rook
takes e8 easy enough bishop takes f5ef
so here
i think if grandelias takes on a4
then something like knight e6 knight f3
i think the position is quite drawish
even though the a3 pawn is likely to
drop i think it'll probably trade for
the d5 pawn
and with four versus four i think a draw
is by far the most likely result
i don't believe that grundelias didn't
see this and this is much to his credit
i think that grundelius was still trying
to win
so rather than play for the drawish
queen takes a4 and i think a draw would
be very likely he tried to win with
queentix f5 i don't know if it was the
objectively correct decision
but i really have to give props i think
that a lot of people having a bad
tournament facing the number two in the
world or maybe i don't know what he is
now exactly but facing someone that
strong would just take the drawage
continuation
and grandelias chose to take a risk and
i do think that
by choosing to take a risk even if you
end up losing the game
you're
you're learning a lot more from that
game than you would if you just took the
easy way out
that being said
objectively you probably should take on
a4 i think that it's just a little bit
safer and better
ah he's number four now that's very sad
he used to be 2800 plus very
consistently but i'm sure he'll get back
there
i i have belief
in any case
so once again i think that
fabi did find a very very accurate
continuation here which was quite
impressive
so what would you play as black
uh i actually didn't know how kara was
playing the grand prix like the slow
tournaments the grand prix because from
what i know like hikaru has been playing
mostly rapid
not so much slow chess i would say that
in rapid i you know
he he's up there without anyone like i i
don't think anyone is a clear favorite
over him necessarily maybe carlson but
in rapid he's right up there especially
if it's online just because he plays
online all the time i think that that's
his best format uh he's obviously an
exceptional classical player but i
wouldn't say he's like
you know
i don't think like 27 the 2750 plus
crowd or 27 70 plus crowd like if he's
quite there with classical but who knows
i mean a lot of it's just because he
doesn't play classical not because he's
not good at that format so
but i didn't know he was actually
playing uh
grand prix that's interesting news
but yeah i would say that like he's
perfectly capable of doing well at
classical chess but he just doesn't play
very much of it
uh these days
bishop takes a3 is a bit of a risky move
i would say
uh bishop takes a3 i think that
this is the kind of thing that grondelus
was looking for and maybe he takes on f7
for example i think that your king is
going to be in danger
and it's not so easy to move these
pieces now as well so i don't know that
i love taking on a3 i think you have to
be a bit more careful
king g8 is possible but i would say that
king g8 is also a very slow move so it
would give white the opportunity for
example to play maybe rook b1 trying to
do something there maybe play knight f3
trying to build his attack or play
bishop d4 or try to solidify
i i think kinji is a little bit slow
f6 also looks just very loose and risky
something like net f3 again i feel like
with bishop d4 as an idea i think it's
going to be bad like let me just show
you like after this i'm going to go here
and then this pawn is just really
horribly weak so i i don't recommend
playing this way either
so jimmy's idea of d4 is correct
so the idea is that you're attacking the
bishop so it moves to f4 and at first
this looks like a perfectly fine square
for the bishop
but fabi's idea here was quite precise
which was 96 very good man and the idea
is that now you're blockading this e
pawn which makes the f4 bishop worse
and trying to take on f7 does not work
so well what do you guys think happens
after it takes on f7
and once again guys i'm trying to read
the chat and everything but uh if i miss
a suggestion or something like that it's
not a personal thing i just don't always
catch all of them
but uh
yeah knight takes f4 and the problem
here is if i play queen takes f4 bishop
g5 is just immensely strong skewering
the queen and knight
so rook a2 is probably a more clever
move but here i can still play queen c3
so if queen takes f4 there's still
bishop g5 so probably you take this way
and now i can simply take on a3 and the
problem is that white's king is really
wide open
and these pieces are completely tied up
the knight can't move the rook can't
move
it's just a position where white's going
to probably just suffer
very badly here because his pieces are
immobile
so rook a2 would have been very clever
but it still doesn't make this very good
the best continuation
i think is actually rook eb1
queen c3 and then knight e4 because now
you get a tempo on the queen
and i think here gondelius has decent
chances like after queen d3 it's still
not simple because his knights pinned
thank goodness he didn't play king ga
right the net of six check would be
available
but here i think that it's about equal
maybe but it's very complicated still
but this is most likely what he should
have gone for
he played 94 right away
and now knight takes up for queen takes
f4
and the move d3
so once again i actually think that with
careful play grundelius maybe would have
some okay
chances but uh there are a couple more
moments in this game so what are the
options that white has here
like i i do think that white's in some
danger but i think that he did have a
way to try to play
more aggressively
actually it is a common problem
the glass is getting fogged up you have
to kind of wear the mask and then put
the glasses over but it's not very
stable all the time
so
it is a common issue
so queen takes f7 i don't think works
out so well
the main issue i believe might just be
queen takes e5 because you don't have a
great discovery with your knight
so because of that uh you gave up your
most dangerous pawn which i think is not
so great knight d6 is the move i worried
about and i originally thought when i
was analyzing because i i always try to
analyze on my own first and then i use a
computer to check how many zillions of
mistakes i made but in general this is
the kind of move which i wanted to play
d2
and then rook d1 and here black actually
has to find a very accurate move to
maintain an advantage
any guesses
so queen takes a1 is so tempting right
but after rook takes a one
rookie one check i can play king g2 for
example
and then take this pawn
and white's doing just fine here i mean
probably will trade a pair of pawns
maybe black has chances if they can if
they can take all these pawns off the
board and have the two rooks against the
queen they have some chances but it's
actually really tough even there because
the pawn on h5 means this king is never
safe
so if you always need a rook to guard
your king you're never going to win
so i don't think this is the most
accurate
queen e5 also i don't think works out
because i can trade and take on d2 and
here white's definitely doing great
yeah taking on e1 jimmy would have
helped you out a lot
yeah queen c2 i believe i can take this
pawn
it's a really tricky move it's it's
again it's not one i saw so
uh and it's it's still not and
altogether obvious all the lines but
it is indeed rookie two
and the idea is you keep the pawn
defended moves like king f1 always run
into queen b5 at least or or something
like that and after d7 you can simply
play rook d8 and the idea is that in
lines where you get to take then
sometimes queen takes a1 rook over and
takes will win because you'll be able to
take this pawn in time
so this turns out to be very very strong
for black but it's still not easy it's
not like the game is over right it's
just
uh very very promising
but i still liked knight d6 i thought
that it was a good practical attempt
he played rookie d1 instead bishop a3
knight d6 bishop d6 so he got kind of a
worse version
but here believe it or not fabi made
maybe one of his big mistakes
uh this position
it looks at first like ah black has the
two past pawns it should be pretty
simple
but it's still possible to
play inaccurately here
and
i think that here and it's move 35 so
i'd suspect time pressure was involved
as well
but you have to be very careful so black
has
quite a few moves at their disposal but
there's one move i really really really
like
ah very good yeah queen b5 is an
extremely strong move
so the whole idea is that you guard d7
you guard their pawn
and you're ready just to push your a
pawn to victory
and this is just incredibly incredibly
strong you can play b5 or d7 but for
example here i can still play rook d8
because my queen covers you don't have
rookie 8 right
if rookie 8 i can simply take
and i don't think you have any clever
shenanigans here
so
queen b5 is very strong and if you try
to take on f7 i can play d2
and queen e2 and this is going to be
over
so kind of a clever
a clever move this queen b5 i really
like it just because it's such a
multi-purpose queen move
the queen on b5 it attacks h5 but it's
almost irrelevant right you just want to
clean your puns
but good to notice that i didn't even
see it at tax h5
but the queen on b5 just kind of does
everything in the world you know
so i said he played queen c3 so my next
question is what could white do to try
to draw and what did fabi blunder what
he blundered was actually not the
least obvious thing in the world but
what do you think he blundered here
so d7 looks nice but queen takes work is
a check unfortunately so that does not
work
yes rook c1
and believe it or not he's actually
already
like he clearly just had to have missed
this move because the problem now is
that if he moves his queen somewhere and
i play d7 with rook c8 coming i think he
might lose i don't think he's even
drawing anymore
so this is a very big problem
after rook c1 so he probably has to play
d2 maybe this was his plan
but after rook takes c3 rook d1 by the
way also probably is just a draw right
rook d8 queen takes d2
and i mean okay usually the way these
end games work is you play a3 and at
some point you trade these two puns
so say i go here you probably go here
and then we agree to a draw at some
point
so rook d1 would just draw very simply
but even rook takes c3 queens
king g2 should be fairly drawish as well
so rook c1 a simple move and all of a
sudden it doesn't look so good
this queen b5
move would have been really really
really really strong
and i would say that probably fabi in
good form would find a move like this uh
more consistently even in time pressure
but i think because he was struggling
this tournament because he hasn't been
himself even you know when he has a
promising position it's not so easy
but i would also say that missing rook
c1 is very easy to do
but it's the kind of move you have to be
careful of all the time
so he plays queen c3 but grandelias also
misses it again i suspect both sides
were in time pressure or at least close
and after rook d1 queen c2 i think his
position is not so great again
he plays queen d2 which doesn't really
work out so well
rook d2 was also possible
but here black has a very very nice
continuation if anyone would like to
find it
it definitely can james like when you
you know and it's also different like
when you're looking at it when from a
from an audience perspective like me a
lot of things might look more obvious or
like wait why do they do this but when
the clock's ticking and you're sitting
there on the board it's
a lot harder so
i always stress that because when i'm
pointing out mistakes i'm not judging
the players or saying how could they do
this it's more just showing how you know
decision making works and how
we can all try to improve on it right
i'm not really going oh how could they
miss this you know
i always like to point that out because
i end up you know i try to point out
when mistakes are made and stuff
rook b2 looks very fancy but i don't
know if it's quite necessary remember
i'm two moves from queening so you have
to be a little careful
rook b1 check is possible and then the
key here is that after king h2 you have
to move queen c6
threatening mate on h1 so f3
and then what's the final move that
really makes white's life miserable
the final nail in the coffin
so queen c1
[Music]
is possible but i think it might allow
king h3 and i can try to run to safety
you have to be careful i still have a
very dangerous d-pawn if you let my king
run it might not be so good
this is a more offense and defensive
move so don't just think offense queen
c1 is just offense but after king h3
maybe i survive
queen c2 i might just push d7 right like
i don't have to take you i might take
you first and push d7 actually that's
probably even easier
and now i think you're going to get
mated first unfortunately
so think offense and defense
remember that queen b5 move was defended
and attacked at the same time
and be careful guys i am threatening
rook takes d3 potentially here or and
also queen takes f7 you want to prevent
these moves
so queen d7 is more defensive i can take
your pawn think defensive and offensive
where do queens love to be
queenie it's kind of clever um but i
don't know if it ends the game or
anything like that i can maybe try queen
e4 for example i don't know this d-pawn
makes me nervous you know
queen d5 very nice
i defend this guy i attack this i do so
these are my defensive things
i'm attacking this i'm attacking this
and you basically are done like i'm just
going to push this button
and that's going to be it
so the centralized queen especially with
few pieces left on the board is just
really really really strong
and this is definitely something to keep
in mind the queen on d5 would be very
very strong
so queen d2 was played
and how do you think fabi finished the
game here
yep he just pushes the pawn and the two
pawns are a bit too much
so d7
are you able to play a2 or not
uh don't allow b8 queen guys
i guess you were saying rook b1 on the
previous move
uh rook b1 here probably does it
um
yeah i don't see anything wrong with it
i guess i could check quickly yeah
completely winning
that would have worked too he played a3
d7
yeah so rook b1 was very very good
he chose something slightly different so
d7
yeah here rook b1 not so much because of
d8
but he goes with a2
and this does the job because now if you
try to take in queen
i can simply take you and go king h7 and
i have two pawns going you can't get
your rook to the first if you could play
rookie one you might even be winning
but you can't stop both pawns from
behind that's kind of the problem
so a2 does the job so gredellius tried
this but fabi simply offered the queen
trade again and here he can't avoid it
because his rook's attacked
so a couple little cute moves just to
guard their kings but in the end
he simply goes for a winning rook end
game rook behind the pawn and here he
wins pretty easily because he just plays
g6 for example brings his king out the
king can run over here and try to take
the pawn but by then white black will
gobble things up so for example if king
d2 i can play g6 for example
you can try this but you're not gonna
really survive
takes and your king is way too far away
so the second you take i can simply take
and run my pun
that's not necessarily a forced line of
course but that's generally the gist of
how you win a position like this
all right thank you trent i appreciate
it
in any case i thought it was a really
really nice game
and really instructive but just the
complications and the way fabi handled
them obviously there were some mistakes
but overall it was
just very very impressive how he kept
his cool against a very strong attack
and a very dangerous looking attack
and both players i thought played really
interesting enterprising tests so i look
forward to finding you know look
checking out how the tournament finishes
and i'll probably be checking out more
games and be going over more of them for
st louis
so i hope you enjoyed this i'll be here
the next few weeks so i hope you enjoy
my lectures and
have a good night everyone or morning
wherever
[Music]
you